[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fin
l'opéra
trop lourd du presque rien
qui tendres la main si je dois trouver
le nom tu es ma chutes
[Musique]
je voudrais retrouver
[Applaudissements]
et bien ne va pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
les enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
incroyable d'abord parce qu'elle est
très belle et vous aussi vous avez la
même manière de marcher le même nez
aussi vous avez fait un petit peu de
chirurgie pour lui ressembler ou pas du
tout pas du tout non
non j'ai jamais fait de chirurgie pour
ressembler à Mylène alors vous vous
appelez Christelle Lee absolument c'est
ça vous êtes socio-officiel mais ça on
veut bien le croire sauf que vous n'êtes
pas un terme que j'aime pas que j'aime
pas trop parce que c'est une étiquette
qu'on nous colle sosie qui me correspond
pas en fait moi je suis juste une
artiste de cabaret je j'ai un show de
transformation enfin de transformation
je transforme rien du tout mais disons
que j'ai un show d'imitation et ça
s'arrête là quoi
il y a plusieurs personnes qui mettent
d'autres d'autres personnes non ça
dépend je joue un peu partout dans les
cabarets mais disons que mon show est
basé sur le personnage de Mylène Farmer
mais disons que je me suis que dans
l'imitation ce cette étiquette de Sosie
c'est quelque chose qui est lourd à
porter je trouve c'est arrivé comme ça à
quel moment vous êtes dit ça y est je
fais ça mais en fait ça fait 20 ans
cette année il y a donc j'ai commencé à
33 ans j'ai commencé à 7h
j'étais j'étais maquilleuse pour le
journal télévisé
avant les journalistes que je maquillais
qui me disait tu lui ressemblent tu
devrais essayer tu es remonter un truc
que j'étais déjà dans le milieu du
spectacle puisque mon ex-mari à l'époque
était musicien de métiers on avait un
studio à la maison je faisais des
costumes de scène pour les autres etc et
du coup je me suis dit tiens je vais je
vais me pencher là dessus et ma sœur
aînée était très fan de Mylène et quand
j'ai vu les vidéos j'ai dit ouais il y a
quelque chose qui m'intéresse dans cet
univers et je veux bien essayer de faire
quelque chose votre ex-mari donc vous
êtes célibataire non je suis aujourd'hui
remarquer quelqu'un
est-ce que la les gens qui regardent la
télévision
[Applaudissements]
maintenant j'ai toujours mon métier de
de Sosie entre guillemets mais on a
aussi des restaurants dans le sud de la
France à Saint-Raphaël exactement où on
travaille beaucoup sur on a une grosse
programmation d'artistes dans nos
établissements on fait beaucoup de
dînées spectacles donc c'est sur le
vieux port de Saint-Raphaël ces deux
gros restaurants qu'on a acheté où on a
pu rassembler les deux terrasses et donc
on fait des dîners spectacles très
régulièrement prévenir des groupes comme
Michael Jones même géraldar mais dans la
rue là vous êtes vraiment extrêmement
arrangé en Mylène Farmer mais dans la
rue quand vous êtes habillé en tous les
jours on vous ressent on vous reconnaît
pardon ou pas honnêtement je suis pas
autant maquillée tous les jours des fois
j'ai ma pince dans les cheveux alors je
vous rassure j'ai déjà vu Mylène Farmer
une fois dans le 16e arrondissement oui
c'était pas maquillage
jamais je me prends pour elle
fait plaisir aux gens ça fait plaisir
aux gens
généreux Mathieu ça fait plaisir aux
gens
j'explique que c'est mon métier
[Musique]
qu'on me pose tout le temps ça fait
plaisir
c'est une question qui est intéressante
et je comprends mais alors non j'ai
jamais je l'ai jamais rencontré je
trouve que c'est une personne qui est
tellement discrète que ça se respecte on
n'a pas envie d'aller chercher quelqu'un
qui qui est aussi discrète et réservée
et en plus j'ai pas grandi avec l'image
de Mylène Farmer comme moi j'étais très
fan de hard rock j'étais guitariste dans
un groupe de rock féminin quand j'avais
20 ans enfin c'était pas mon université
alors je pense que oui parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui surveille beaucoup son
image d'accord mais un petit mot un
petit truc non non mais par contre je
profite de cette occasion pour la
remercier parce que je pense que grâce à
grâce à elle et son personnage j'ai eu
une carrière pendant 20 ans une carrière
artistique extraordinaire qui m'a fait
vivre des moments formidables comme être
là aujourd'hui
vu votre talent et votre beauté qui
n'est pas terminé